let's do an example of how a housing
bubble can lead to wealth destruction
and i really just want to hit the point
home that once wealth is destroyed all
legislation can do is kind of
redistribute who takes the losses that
you can't create wealth all of a sudden
out of legislation you can maybe create
incentives for investment et cetera et
cetera but we'll talk about that in a
future video so let's say in year one i
have a neighborhood a new you know toll
brothers goes out and builds a new
development and they build five houses
let me draw those five houses
house one
house two
house three
house four
and house five
and let's say that this was a a normal
uh home buying environment this could
have been i don't know 1995 actually
let's just say let's just for the sake
of argument let's say that this is 1995.
1995. although i want this to be an
abstract example so we could call that
year one
but in 1995 these people
they find you know five new families
that go by the house they pay a hundred
thousand each for the house
they pay a hundred thousand
for the houses each family
100 000. and these were conforming loans
there wasn't this whole
cdo and mortgage-backed security market
so essentially these people had to put
20 percent down and they had good credit
scores and all the rest so immediately
they have twenty thousand dollars of
equity and an eighty thousand dollar
loan right 20k equity
20k
equity that's my code e for equity and
then eighty thousand loan i don't have
to write that down or 80 000 mortgage
right and they had good credit etc etc
now we have this whole securitization
lending becomes a lot easier it becomes
easier and easier every year because the
housing prices go up so people
stop taking risk into consideration and
let's say that where we get to the year
2005
but this could be an abstract example it
could be year two whatever in 2005 all
of a sudden everyone has
everyone is getting access to funding
the people who have houses actually
don't want to sell their houses because
they're convinced that their housing
prices is go are going up so fast that
it's only a matter of time before they
are millionaires just with their housing
wealth and then they could maybe retire
off of it
but there's so much funding anyone can
get a loan and let's say that this first
homeowner maybe they have to move or
maybe they just want to move to a
cheaper location or maybe their kids
have gone to college so they just want
to downsize they decide to sell their
house and because there's so much demand
out there anyone can get a loan frankly
the person who's going to be able to
give the highest bid in the house is a
person to some degree who's most
reckless or or most prudent and anyway i
won't go into that but let's say they
pay a million dollars for the house
right they have no money down million
dollar
loan sub prime negative amortization
they had no credit rating etcetera
etcetera well they pay a million dollars
that was the purchase price of the house
and we could just say you know they have
zero equity
and they have a million loan
and of course this guy is great now
let's just you know he he probably did
build equity over that 10 years from
1995 to 2005 but even if he didn't even
if all he did is he paid the interest on
this 80 000 loan this guy he had 20 000
now he gets a million pays off the 80 so
he essentially gets
he essentially gets 920 000 plus then
the 20 000 he had before so he you know
he moves
to costa rica or whatever with 940 000
and lives like a king
although i've heard costa rica has also
become expensive
but anyway
what happens now in the neighborhood
these people didn't sell their houses
they didn't find some some subprime
individual that was willing to bid up
the house they didn't nothing happened
no money changes hands but all of a
sudden these people say well you know
what our houses are just as nice as this
first house that sold
maybe it's even better
so our houses are also worth a million
dollars
so we all have this kind of you could
say paper
wealth here of a million dollars just
from one transaction and actually this
is a five house neighborhood this could
happen in a in a 500 house neighborhood
you just have to find one person to
overpay for a house and then everyone in
the neighborhood all of a sudden feels
that their house is worth that much
and just out of thin air just by one
person getting cheap credit and
overpaying for something everyone in the
neighborhood thinks that they just got
nine hundred thousand dollars of wealth
or at least in this example
you never see a nine-fold increase sorry
a nine a nine-fold increase in property
prices but you have it wasn't crazy to
see a twofold increase in a year
over the last well we have seen ninefold
increases over ten years which is the
example here so it's actually not that
crazy anyway that's their
that's all of their notional wealth
but all these people you know they don't
want to sell one they like their house
their kids are still there
and they say wow you know in 10 years my
house went from a million from 100k to 1
million and another 10 years my house is
going to go from i don't know a million
to 10 million why would i sell it i can
then retire off the house they don't
think who could buy a 10 million dollar
house in in in 10 years the only people
who could well anyway i'll do another
video on that i just want to run out of
time
but they but they can still monetize
this they could say well you know
when i go to my financial planner they
said oh it's it's so inefficient for you
to have all of that equity sitting in
your house right how much equity do they
have they had 20 000 before and even if
they didn't build any equity while they
paid their mortgage they now have
another 900 000
of equity
right so these these people um their
financial planners say oh and and their
their their siblings and whatever say
and their friends at work say oh your
balance sheet is so inefficient why
don't you take some of that equity and
invest it or put it to work so they say
oh that's a good idea i'll go get a home
equity loan so let's say this person
they go to a bank
a bank says okay sure i'll give you
a 500 000 home equity loan
five hundred thousand dollar home equity
loan and in exchange
get i don't know eight percent
interest on that loan so this is the
bank
and the bank thinks it got a great deal
because this 500 000 loan it's not just
it's not an unsecured loan it's not like
if this person can't pay they just file
bankruptcy and there's nothing that the
bank can get a hold of this home equity
loan is secured by the house so the bank
says well if this person doesn't pay
that five hundred thousand dollar loan
if they default for whatever reason
i get their house and their house is
worth a million dollars right and why do
i think it's a million dollars because a
house in the neighborhood sold for a
million dollars and frankly that's how
um unfortunately housing was assessed
people would just say oh another house
in this neighborhood sold for a million
this one must be worth a million because
it's a very similar or maybe it's even a
better house so this banker thinks they
have a great deal this is better than
lending to buying treasuries i'm getting
eight percent maybe treasuries are
giving me three to three or four percent
and if they default on it i actually get
an asset that's probably worth more than
the loan amount and i can auction that
off and easily get
my five hundred thousand dollar bank so
the the risk managers within the bank
think they have a great deal and they
probably slice and dice these things and
sold it to other people and got it ready
to distribute all of that
but what happens next well let's say
2005 in in our imaginary universe was
the peak of of the credit cycle that was
the year that credit was the loosest and
as soon as some of these uh people who
had no jobs and and and and got this
these million dollar loans they probably
couldn't even pay
pay the the fine pay the mortgage on
their loan not to speak of you know
continuing it or they probably could
even pay the low rate on the original
teaser loan so maybe they start to
default credit starts getting tighter
and um and let's say this guy actually
gets foreclosed and so he gives the
house back to the bank the bank
auctions it off and let's say when the
bank auctions it off it only gets
i don't know it only gets 300 000 for
the house
it only gets three hundred thousand
dollars for the house and in the
meantime what did all of these people do
with their five hundred thousand dollars
that they had
well they they their intention was to
take these home equity loans and
put put that money to work invested in
some way
and they say oh what what's a better
investment than doing home improvements
because we all know a house is the best
investment so unfortunately a lot of
that five hundred thousand dollars it
gets quote unquote invested
in granite countertops
granite countertops two more bathrooms
per house
more bathrooms
hardwood floors
are let's say wood floors
and and you can imagine and you know
they want to treat themselves too so
they did a little vacation so it was
invested in quote unquote invested in
their house because they said oh well
you know this will increase the value of
my house and oh as a side benefit i will
really look good relative to the
neighbors and and and live it up and and
i can live beyond essentially what my my
income would predict would predict and
i've done some videos on investment
versus consumption but i'd argue that
this wasn't real investment that five
hundred thousand dollars that this was
consumption because it's not making the
world more productive in any way it's
not increasing the total economic pie
for the world so it's not an investment
it may be it is investment if it if it
somehow makes your asset more
emotionally appealing to some greater
fool to pay more for it but it's not
it's like you didn't build a factory or
you didn't invent some new technology
that will make all of us richer you just
poured some money into something that's
going to make your lifestyle a little
bit better and maybe the next person who
buys your house
but anyway this house got for closed on
it's now worth it gets auctioned off it
gets auctioned off for 300 000 maybe
this is the year 2006.
now all of a sudden all of these people
probably all of whom who took these home
equity loans let's say all of them did
it right they all say gee i'm paying a
500 000
loan actually i'm paying 500 000
plus my original 80 000 loan so i have i
have 580 000 of debt
on an asset that just sold for three
hundred thousand dollars so what do you
think they're gonna do and i just
realized i'm out of time so i'll
continue this in the next video